yeah hello and welcome to yet another
tea session video still have to wait
some minutes before it's ready now let's
get going with the game three plus two
we get one there
sonson okay
I am going to do this video today and
for tomorrow
we'll be December first I'm going to go
form oh that certainly move
to remove though taking on c5
and really probably call that much
or is it going for here so if I take
before going to be dangerous and that
looks like a pretty good Sicilian to me
with some odd pieces here
Bishop on g5 if I go Queen b6 is there
something particularly
bad happening I'm attacking f2 and I'm
awesome
attacking b2
okay 22 then the Queen b6 Queenie -
Queen B - rupee one we need 395 as an
annoyance
I'm just going to continue to develop
the three plus two right so after must
be stay on track that I'm not
getting and the time
into
be this first
huh
we're taking efore and preparing to go
d5
also a just have to speed up a little
bit because
and it's okay I'm ten seconds behind I
don't want to fall too much behind on
the clock
I'm going to do a different video a
different kind of video it will be me
solving some chess exercises
not so much technical ones but rather
we are more complex positions more of an
enolate analytical exercise
now he won't be able to Castle queenside
anymore
which is what he probably had on his
mind
um think I should be
find him this pawn structure is really
not looking all that great the question
is how am I going to set up my pieces I
think e5
what about b6 but if five makes a good
impression yeah there was one point yeah
I can go in for now and win the bishop
right
so e5 was coming with the tempo his
queen is unprotected
it's the thing
I mean it didn't expect him to blunder
the piece but it's always nice to have a
little technical point yeah with your
with your move there they might miss it
yeah okay so let's go for me at the game
and in a couple of minutes there is a
blitz tournament
one of those our leave blitz events and
I think I could join that at some it's a
good alternative
and I should also be able to him
get games quite quickly
I would have to wait for anywho any
opponents night be six years the move
Knight c3 Queen c3 is awkward yeah I get
that a lot
well people don't expect the Queen
capture but this is just awful I mean
okay black is not losing straight away
or anything like that but you can
definitely see that black wanted to have
something else he didn't want to play f6
now he's stuck without gasoline
[Music]
what is he doing there preparing Bush
should be six
market
you
um I don't know I should have done that
differently maybe a Bishop f4 arm would
have been a cute idea if the pawn is not
oh now he can take Bishop e6 stick on
your phone I'm losing material
you
I now we can actually castle there that
wasn't good
the position is very very nice for me
but I should have played differently
okay
you
now how do we play this I would really
like to check the Queen here on the six
such a that should barely place peas
you
Oh
you
yeah I feel I could have done better
you
yeah I kind of expected that to happen
it looks awfully weakening but it's the
only somewhat active possibility that
black has now there are some technical
things probably going on here based on
the pin
like a Queen f6 Queen b6 moves like that
okay I'm going to play this here anyway
because Bishop h5 is not really what
black ones
he wanted to after he takes a five take
with the bishop
now Queen b6 is that really how much of
a problem is that
not much of a promise on him let's take
him
you
my basic idea is if I move the Queen
let's say it takes with the pawn on f5 I
play Queen d3
the check is pawn but i also threaten
Knight B 5 and then d6 check which would
win the house yeah c7 hangs everything
hangs
so I'm not quite sure what his move is
now and maybe not
well I'm actually threatening to take a
five I mean
if he plays like King edge 8 okay it
does not react in any kind of way
probably he had nothing that he could do
but okay no Knight b5 and b6 check
I can take your five there's nothing
particularly wrong about that
I mean where's the Queen actually going
No
to do it
you
okay
it all comes with tempo here on my end
the bishop now is attacked
before next also again with the big
tempo
[Music]
Knoblauch is falling apart him
sorry for them slurping noises some the
tea is really hot at the very beginning
of such a session difficult
now what
where do you go now
yeah rookie one him
you
now what is the quickest way to win this
position we should be five Bishop f5x on
d6 should be fairly easy
got something else wind xe5 is a fancy
way to play
it's also completely winning
yeah but come on
I've written some books sir
keep it simple for a reason because I
know if I don't keep it simple I'm doing
stupid stuff so it's indeed keep it
simple
okay now I will I think I'll take it
going to be a good way to do it I'm two
pawns up and I have a chick where I
check him
and now the seven I guess
yes establish that pond
that is completely tying up like
you
we can he can absolutely not move him
you
No yeah okay taking us probably the
easiest thing to do
you
many pawns
you
you
you
and
sure if I'm doing this right this is not
the best technical play ever but the two
parts should really be enough
know what I did wrong there actually
you
it still wins with this
oh maybe it doesn't win
cheese's
believe that I'm screwing this up
unbelievable
Wow that this that is painful
this is oh Jesus
yeah I felt like I was built falling
asleep during this game and I don't know
a g6 is better but this is still winning
what am I doing here
even even here I am
what's wrong this is just stupid
just one move too slow I mean I'm the
thing is this is promoting on its own
Ruka g 7 h 7 g 6g 8 h 8 I just have to
go to the pawn now that was just a
complete brain fart this is easy now I'm
controlling the pawn and this is this is
promoting on its own I just I just I
just played this first and now I'm just
one move to slow it was super stupid oh
my god okay so there's this tournament
right
I will D what do we have we have a blitz
arena and a super blitz arena yeah okay
I think I'm going for the 5 minute this
is a bit more a bit more me
fitting for them for the commentary
show how this works with them with the
screen setup
Oh
not used to that
Ling
you know this should be okay right miss
Dark Soul
hmm okay let's go
got some some choice them we've got
thirty-six minutes tournament time that
is okay right it fits well with the
usual length of such a video this is a
bit imprecise at this particular moment
but not terribly bad for white III is a
good choice once white is there
that's what
she absolutely does not belong on d3m
hmm well I can probably not punish it
some wavered
a bit strange
now how do we play white always wants to
really wants me to take
you
search and how I should lay this I'm
probably going with Bishop d7 rook c8 a6
p 5a DM
what White has is basically some um yeah
some Tom whomped has a version of Amarok
C bind he doesn't even have before and
he cannot play for it doesn't really
want to take on c6 and it's not quite
clear or you continue if you have the
bishop only to as it is usual you can
maybe play Bush you have three ideas
like that it's still on a pretty
harmless for black
but White has a solid position now this
is definitely definitely the case
so probably wants to put a book on the
one
you
now I'm going to play Bishop g4 here
trying to
Volker weakness I don't think he wants
to go into his health pin yep doesn't
want to do that and I'm just going back
in order to win against such a solid
structure and of course I'm not better
here just equal ish in order to win
against such a solid structure and
sometimes good you just provoke some
some small concession and f3s it's not a
big deal
but I'm happy that yes we can to
structure a little bit now do we have
any any interesting way to go here um
and wonder if he really wants to play
before that's
not really
I'd normally wants to do
maybe he still wants to play it it just
weakens wide but he's doing it anyway
okay
or she's doing it could be really a
female of course
no I cannot take this
take it and probably I should because
the night xd4 send a check on the Queen
okay that is actually really nice for me
I didn't see that before hand because
Bishop takes d4 I can take on c1 this is
very nice
and point ext4 is really not what white
intended to do
this is a case where f3 comes in handy
because Queen b6 then d4 actually hangs
with a check this is very nice
not sure what white is contemplating
here because
you have to take with the pawn but what
is there what is the thought
before Quincy one that looks like a bad
thing to do
okay now
[Music]
I cannot really do something straight
away like we should before then Quincy
one doesn't work unfortunately but Queen
b6 seems what I'm going to claim
attacking d4 here with the check
covered it
I can still be taken on Poisson
[Music]
how do we do this I would definitely
like
to recapture on c8 with the rookin case
of the capture ongoing Bishop f6
covering a seven
yeah I think one one thing Wow
these tournaments is that you have to
take into account that sometimes winning
quickly is a thing
they have to be
that I'm not play too slowly
g-form
you
yeah let's go eat five come on I'm I'm
helping I'm helping her to get rid of
the double pawn here with D take six but
I thought opening up the position
against G for here must be a good idea
so takes six rupees six and then the
Queen doesn't have such a clear any good
square to go to probably to f2 and then
I wanted to play but should be five
queen f forum should be five so now I
wanted to play Bishop b5 trying to
infiltrate
yeah maybe maybe there is d5 by white
five could be bit of an annoyance
five d 5 something like that bad
Willie
that's a bit of a pain okay so let's
stop it
should be 5 next
watch out this is non increment
important I tend to forget that because
I'm such a minion in the increment mode
and then all of a sudden oh my god I
have no time
yeah so that was the idea get rid of my
questionable bishop and get into a
position where White's Bishop is bad
that was the thing that d-5 accomplished
that now d5 from white it's not possible
anymore
guess with the Queen getting the tempo
now yeah I can definitely just take and
play queen d3
not sure if it's best it can also allow
the capture
maybe not such a bad idea right after
every six my pawn on d5 is safely
covered
and king f7 will always cover e6 and the
white queen is not easily entering this
is probably not a bad choice
now why does somewhat tied down to the
defense of the default pawn
maybe Quincy 3 is her idea here
now why can you not take me boy
I think I can take it
trick I don't see it
you
in aged six maybe on I can check here
first
see what I'm going to do
[Music]
let's go deform
to keep keep an eye on the time
we'll give AF
still a danger of getting getting into a
perpetual here early
oh I go stupid if I go here Queenie [ __ ]
don't have Queen g5 because this
checkmate
a bit stuff
eleven seconds it's not increment or I'm
stupid
ten seconds will be very difficult now
mm-hmm
you
okay yeah Oh
just to that time a little bit she could
have easily won on time
you know there was a long game and just
a draw so even though I'm a huge
favorite in this tournament that could
be already the end of it
airing players takes a long time why
don't I get a game
I thought that was wicker procedure
have to do this
in order to catch up
you
it's a huge point you know for black
hair next move will decide the course of
the game he can take on c4 d4 or play
something like this should be seven it
should be seven runs into him leads to
him
the tirage or here the so called semi
tirage it's a pretty comfortable line
white
you
I can actually play five I cannot take
this there was a bit rush to this move
you
because I have to be somewhat quicker
after the the berserk but shouldn't we
do it
with the QuickPlay
yeah minutes and half knocker I've got
no increments um
key business
you can take b2 b1 I think this is very
dangerous
now if I take from the Queen has to take
but I can do this here maybe
it's going to be not so easy to answer
for him I hope retaining bishop takes of
six
made on h7 is the deal
I don't really know how its defending it
I mean you can play the rocky Rock the
arrowhead and Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen h7 to move the king that is
definitely possible
but he has to find this first I mean
now he will find that it's not so
difficult then probably maybe rooks c1
is putting the most pressure on him
you
now look da torre aids I go look c1 I
guess I don't have a true direct wind I
mean I can check him yeah okay my twins
exchange at least
promote this we never know
play whatever we should be - or so and
then I rather yeah yeah
and he went when we should be - okay
yeah just Ruby one I guess
ah what
[ __ ] I'm sorry that is crazy
I had touched a five and then I wanted
to go look we want any play Bishop b1
Wow
Wow
right I mean wide well I was winning but
basically every move not not the one not
the one that was then
the bishop b1 was the worst possible
move
oh my god
you
some of the game is still continuing
it is lost but
in one my god these things are really
really unnerving
I think I'm winning this MMS to winning
this which is crazy
you
and that whatever I mean what a crazy
game all of a sudden Bishop B oneness
played shoot
that was shocking
at this moment you could basically play
almost anything and win but not we
should be
okay yeah I was hoping to get paired
more quickly
because the waiting time for the regular
blitz games are sometimes a little bit a
bit long came circus
we do the pre moving his six is a good
move
now I know him for this for example you
don't want to play to e6 against Knight
c3 and all of a sudden I get a French
defense
not that the French is so terrible but
it's just not the best thing that you
can get against 93
now this looks pretty nice easy
development maybe G for now play this
attempt to quickly
and that I'm not really leaving and all
that much
why it should take on c-51 CS played f3
maybe maybe you can go before now
you
yeah it looks very nice for me
own up basically
no I'm pulling up for real and white
still has
some questions to answer like where to
go with the king
couple of good options maybe Bishop
before even
Knight takes e4 Knight takes d4 is awful
and now I'm threatening on c2 and I'm
threatening the bishop and on g2 and
everything bind should net me even more
material this is actually pretty good
because the bishop here cannot run
there's just no square for it and if he
takes night eggs I'm winning the rook so
I won a piece
and there's absolutely no compensation
for it whatsoever
[Music]
so that should be an easy win even with
one minute something on the clock
you
yeah good that observed this one
was were some easy easy points there
Cam's still behind
that first game was really costly
yeah that let's draw a draw that took 10
minutes I think this is additionally
problematic
so this guy berserk in two games
okay I shouldn't bouzouki adds the
number 12 player Snowville I think just
a normal game is good
each six is very early but it's it's
going to fit into blacks position
um yeah here he has a choice of various
Queen moves mostly Queen b6 is played
wins the aide of course is also possible
he now has to think about okay he didn't
think about it but
or to be taken and then playing a night
would be five 195 can also be tricky I
think I'm going 95 this is probably
posing some more problems okay you just
went away with the noid are we going a
45 I think I will do that huh
if five now is a threat not so easy to
handle this a five-night goes back and
then I take on d5 yeah here this is
almost the same thing so a five what is
he doing then 90 85
Oh pawn takes Knight c4 90/65 looks
pretty bad
you
hmm it's true it's actually interesting
so should cheeks up on cheeks
go to sea for anyway
I think this is good night c4 and then I
have a couple of technical options
and wonder what's best I wanted to go
originally Knight takes d5
but 95 pawn takes Bishop takes he has
Knight takes a 5 I guess
and this is a bit of a bit of a problem
[Music]
the alternative is a form that should
also be pretty good
ma'am boy looks like a good
Knight a5 I go Queen a4 that is a double
attack on Bishop and tonight pawn takes
Queen takes e4 so he probably has to
play the Bishop to e6 and then I just
take the five and should be in great
shape
now which
[Music]
don't see how he is
keeping
always holding this together
maybe something crazy like g5 or so
you
yeah it's probably the only move
it looks it looks bonkers but the only
move maybe because I cannot move the
bishop
so how do we play this if I take on d5
by plane night eggs
a
in the most logical movers to take here
so let's do this first and then I'm
thinking about the details
v6 sorry f6 looks pretty awful I can
also take on d5 this is still part of
this position 95 point X Bishop takes
Queen takes a five-night xf 5 now I can
also do other stuff
twin d3 for example
we moves f6 Rockets completely crushing
you
it's completely crushing come on let's
do this
you
night 85 I wanted to move the Queen to
d3
okay I didn't see that coming
and I'm not sure that it is any good but
I didn't see it at all
so queen d3
and also take just take on si ATM
I don't think this is enough
you know
these three should be should be good
I'm going to d3 also because I want to
cover a five
in need ideas f6 next f6 and threatens
Queen g6 with mate into
but okay probably he plays queen d8
anyway
doesn't play India okay
yes
scrap the queendom
red is Queen g6 with maid
you
yes to check on f6 oh it's just nothing
else really
you
Kim
that looked pretty nice so I'm getting
closer but this guy here mind 93 is
Boozer King every game and wins it's
difficult to stop I probably have to be
paired against him and then win this
game
yeah okay the last two games were I
think okay before that that was a bit
shaky okay the game with Bishop and one
was more of a mouse issue on whatever
okay
yeah the Kings Indian attack is fairly
harmless against
knight c6 on move - because you get to
play the board winning setup which is
more or less equalizing right over the
bed
okay I don't like that
this is looking pretty nice
like now um
and expand quickly with f5 but I'm going
to stop his immediate expansion here
you're really playing Bishop h6 year
ocean maybe
okay I'm going to
go for small
teaching rap yeah which she falls into
now I'm getting an eternal night on
deform
everything with tempo and then night
lens on the amazing d4 square
you know this is very nice
Oobleck as the white bishop is a real
dummy
we'll never be a good piece
trying to be annoying with queen-to-be
form I'm happy to
now I'm effectively a pawn up three
against two while the Queen side is
completely frozen
battening 92 or Ruby 2
now he probably has to play something
like
yeah like this and now going to be forum
in trade is of course pretty nice for me
and he did not do it but I can take em
and then play a five setting my majority
in motion them most
sure what the right word is for that
let's say Prozac winter way to witness
to just trade everything trade the rooks
I mean and then win the ending night
against Bishop
I'm basically a pawn up III pawn is
completely irrelevant here
you
i blundered before
or stool axiom
that was that was very unnecessary
maybe that wasn't immediately lost but
completely
or elders to allow
yeah I'm relaxing a bit too much because
I know that the position under normal
circumstances is an easy win
when John and I'm
paying as much attention as I should
so let's set this in motion
you
you
this is the best way to do it then King
g5 and rupee three
his bishop is really absolutely
terrible
okay now how do we play this a couple of
things that I can do a for immediately
is certainly possible
but I wonder if that is the best way to
play
it's really easiest without the rooks
but I don't see how I'm trading trading
them so easily
[Music]
you
yeah but honestly there's really not
much that you can do here on the checker
can even play Knight f3
it cannot
anything then
you
you three is hanging now
a Shoji to
look f1 rookie to check actually made
yeah that's made
you
it looked like a fairly clean strategic
win Oh mind 93 lost the game that's a
good one
me
let's see maybe I still get paired with
them that would be good
you sit ahead of me
and I shouldn't be lose a game a that
would really allow unsure people to
overtake me
to mind is playing and he he preserved
again he seems to be Zerg every game
I'm not sure if I should buzzer key I
just play a normal game I guess I'm
normally not doing all that well with
the buzzer King
and eighteen hundreds they a bit of a
mixed bag some of them really play well
[Music]
yeah we had that before and this is a
huge part of my keep it simple G for
book
you
these Slav setups are really popular
you
mmm I was just thinking if I have
something
I'm technical here if I take on d5 and
sacrifice the night but no it's in quite
work
maybe it does work actually if we if we
look at this CT XE takes 95-pound takes
25 now the rook is hanging right
so there must be night a six or 97 and
okay 1974 actually wins material back
you to be five but he has night to a six
this is a problem because after if for
no the bishop is actually hanging on or
all night before I can take on f5 hmm so
what am I missing here or am I just
winning material
let's do it come on if I'm if I'm
miscalculating this is not the end of
the world
you
very quickly played I think you should
have taken a moment at least so now if I
am that was my idea
the bishop is attacked which should be
six at 86 and if the bishop moves
elsewhere I go if five with a big Fork
one relevant line is Bishop g4 each five
green a five-night h4
yeah I can intake 26 okay now if five
that was the point
you
oh this one okay d7 now also attacked
okay pawn takes is the easiest move
nice office good him night eggs is also
strong but
No yeah I was thinking night h4 this is
some
more or less a double attack
also checking the book
maybe I should okay his next move is
probably work t-888
how come this is - is still a Google
let's do it
oh that's very nice
now I'm winning the house to pin
it's very nice because it speeds up the
win
and I know the leaders a little bit
larger three points
and I got I played the most games of the
whole bunch yeah okay there wasn't about
a quick one such a quick witness use
form
yeah the view is not so bad yeah you can
see all the reported information
yeah I need to not we do it with them
that's that's the second place right
Libba deaf
so it's kind of important
you
you
come I have completely forgotten all
this line worked should be 7 or 97
[Music]
or Bishop is 6 mm I don't know I have to
if to speed up a little bit
it's so pretty awful that I forgotten
this I mean I made a series on that the
newman's of our goals in repertoire
we offer forget it so early I'd okay
it's probably not a big deal I think I'm
okay yeah anyway this Bishop 192 and not
be overly critical
[Music]
we're in this form
[Music]
you
okay
actually it's stupid that I'm thinking
about it because I have to play this
move anyway
now this
I got this counterplay he takes but he
has knight c6 so I cannot immediately
take I think I'm going to go over p8
and ask him about his next move
there are similar positions with the
bishop on b2 and these are a bit better
for white but not winning or hugely
advantageous and it really cannot be
that fantastic with the bishop on a1
yeah it's a fairly normal idea but g6s
on the on my agenda anyway any term
Carbonite f5
yeah as I said this is not something
particularly uncommon
yeah the bishop to c8 would be good but
it's difficult to yet
the end of the way to arrest the Queen
him
he wants to take on d5
you
it takes you for as 96
you
not sure about the smooth but let's do
it the ladies rook check c1 maybe he can
simply allow that like see txt 5 now
because he has this knight c6 idea maybe
that is actually possible
[Music]
yeah that was stupid actually seat xt5
no strong
rupee one rupee one Bishop T to 96 is
completely devastating
that is bad
it's really bad
what can i play that actually after cd5
and I do something entirely different
them
I know that was a bad idea
that was a bad idea
ah that was a huge mistake after cd5 I
don't see a move actually
oh I was lucky
I mean I'm not saying that this is
fantastic for me but the other line was
utter devastation I was really just
completely completely terrible okay now
came yeah I'm still not
entirely clear what I'm doing
yeah Bishop c3 the rook moves and
divorces garbage
you
[ __ ] before
such a bad move
really really
yeah there was really not well thought
out
come on
now he cannot take because he was
hanging
- into serious time time pressure anyway
him
boom
equip
[Music]
you
85 looks extremely natural
okay I can take Knight f6 and then rook
c5 that is actually pretty awkward
rook c5 is an interesting option anyway
that I need to
[Music]
be aware of
even night see to walk c5 is interesting
let's do it threatening rook h5 winning
the Queen
and g4 h5 is awkward
or white
yes that's good
ship c8
yes I like this I'm thinking I'm getting
getting somewhere
95 is a good idea
yeah
I'm okay I'm okay
and I mean like more than okay I think
I'm better now but it's still of course
very complicated
you know he has a hard time to improve
his PC says it looks pretty pretty
uncoordinated
you
mmm yeah I came at him what are you
doing against this one mean taking
wasn't bad either
Oh
it is pretty huge self pin
so Quincy seven
Thank You five
you
you
let's do it anyway that will be some
kind of
a time issue in some way
you
you
after speed up twenty something seconds
I don't want to trade Quincy actually
maybe like this
you
is not very quick fortunately
so it's not a some messy dogfight at the
end where everything is yeah just
depending on Mouse skills
okay the funky pairing 1,500
it is on six place so after
knowledge that
you should play t4 or one
that's odd
maybe there was a mouse slip I wanted to
place he takes d5
you
what about I'm not quite sure about the
rules here these tournaments have
haven't played for a long while do I get
to play this till the end or what about
the clock is that really after eight
minutes it just is over
[Music]
I think I need to win yeah otherwise
London Yangon or query might overtake me
[Music]
you
okay
resisting
yeah sometimes it can be an idea to take
with the bishop and shut to be such a
position put more pressure on deform but
and doesn't doesn't feel
right I can also just keep the bishop
and play see six next
that is some strengthening my porn
structure and I can ultimately put
pressure on default so with g6 Bishop g7
later
I'm a pawn up after all I don't really
need to vary that much
about how to win I just have to convert
the pawn
okay Queen d7 for Bishop f5 that might
be Queen a form
[Music]
yeah that is not so comfortable
you
my intention is night be six nights you
four
you
white-only has a check on age 7 this is
not really
some
okay
like I would still like to trade the
LightSquared Bishop with Bishop f-fire
is currently on that the way I'm not
threatening this straightaway but I
would like to have this possibility
in some cases at least
you
like Ian now I can play this move
you can take on C form for opposite
colored bishops but it should be very
good for me still
after D takes
avoiding the trade but now I can double
on the e-file
you
fifty-three
six doesn't
much
we're really not sure about the rules
here if I how quickly after windows to
make this game count
as I might I might need the win
yeah somebody
as first place at the moment
you
yeah he probably won't take it
but you can try
so let's push this back
you
okay
and mostly one too
quick dome that I have
chances to finish this before the clock
runs out
you
didn't see this one
it's not maybe even f6 here f6 Bishop b2
[Music]
let's take it
I don't really mind this
night against bishops not a bad scenario
here
the two minutes they they concern me
maybe this is completely
unproblematic I'm not so sure about the
rules as mentioned
and he's defending this quite well after
the completely catastrophic opening he's
doing a good job
you
I have a simple idea Queen c7 Queen b6
pick it up
okay now maybe a form
you
pick up the pawn next
20 seconds think I'm going to do it even
in the time
she can do o6 here
you know it can still take
though the night is such an awesome
defender
nann desert no chicks the night is
really sometimes a good piece oftentimes
it's terrible but sometimes it's great
okay um just okay I'm just giving some
chicks
it's not going to make the time
you know
I have enough yeah crypto group to
nopales actually lost the last game so
I'm winning this comfortably I got this
one draw at the beginning that was a bit
of a problem and think other than that
it was okay some interesting games so
not a bad not a bad experience this
tournament um my performance wasn't
great yeah that however this one draw is
killing my performance or did I make
another draw
Oh
didn't I just make one wrong
that's crazy
that seven seven point five out of eight
such a low performance
pretty strange why am i wrong there
would though with that with the results
of a check
and one all those
I just made the one draw and it was so
costly sting yeah okay well I lost five
points with the draw and then
yeah I don't get any points for wins
against 1800 yeah okay even get not even
one like one courtesy point or something
you get absolutely nothing okay so I won
that tournament and I thought it was an
entertaining thing for a change I hope
you enjoyed it I'll be back tomorrow
with as I mentioned some chess analysis
some chess yeah studying solving
positions thanks for watching bye bye
you